I mean I think there are there are a
couple of things when one is something
that we certainly everybody sees that
there's just been a tremendous amount of
upheaval in in the new space and beyond
just sort of the new space in in content
creation overall I mean the Internet has
been really just a phenomenal thing I
don't think anybody would would would
argue that the internet hasn't brought
this great opportunity for users to get
new information from so many different
sources in so many different ways and
really to own that experience and be
much more much more in control of what
they read and where they read it from
but that is as meant a significant
change to the business model so if you
look at at a in the past if you at a
local newspaper that was your one source
for information if you you know the
buffalo news for example if I wanted to
get information about Buffalo sure that
was my that was my key source if I
wanted information about wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan that was my source if I
wanted to know what was going in
Washington about the debate over about
health care overhaul again I Buffalo
News was my source for all that
information online it's so easy to
navigate to so many different sources
that you no longer have that
stranglehold on information and I think
everybody would argue that that's that's
that's a tremendous thing for for the
end users but it's challenged with the
business model you no longer have that
sort of local monopoly so that's one
thing I think that just Google sometimes
becomes synonymous with the internet for
in good ways and in bad ways so anything
good that happens with the internet
that's Google and anything bad that
happens because of the Internet that's
Google as well so I think part of it is
just is just that I mean we are sort of
associated with with some of the
disruption so I think that's part of it
the other is this sense that that google
gets value from indexing the content and
in that case i think everybody google
would agree one hundred percent there's
no doubt that google receives value from
our ability to index high quality
information on on the web whether it's
news or otherwise if there's not high
quality information on the web not much
to search for so we definitely receive
value from that i don't think that's in
dispute but i think that the part where
there's sometimes as a disconnect which
is the value that we deliver back to
publishers while we do get value from
indexing
um it's to help people find that
information so we in turn drive again
the you know the traffic that I talked
about going off to publishers there
there's significant value that we
deliver to publishers and that's not
even getting into the different tools
that we have available to help them make
a better website things like Google Maps
or YouTube's where they can leverage our
technology to make for a better website
and obviously the whole part of our
business that deals with helping them
monetize it whether it's things like
Adsense contextual advertisements or
double-click which is ad serving
technology so not even touching those
those business relationships that we
there there is either Google receives
but there's also a significant amount
that we deliver back to publishers
I think they're I think there are there
are a couple things I mean some of the
issues that I was you know just talking
about just the general I think
challenges of a changing business model
but you know as I said I think that we
we do deliver value back to publishers
but it as far as whether it's legal or
not we we respect copyright law and you
know if we showed no more than a
headliner stupid sort of what's
considered fair use but it's sort of
it's it's not even a legal debate
because there's no there's no you know
we don't force any publisher to give us
their content so in the case of a
publisher who decided they want to put
content on the web but didn't want
Google to crawl it that's very easy to
do you can do that either by contacting
us or simply by putting a bit of code on
the page or something called robots.txt
which is I mean at its most extreme says
do not crawl the site at all and you can
you can direct that to specific search
engines you can say i want i want yahoo
to crawl us but I don't want Google to
crawl this but there's also a number of
different fine grained controls that
publishers have within a broader
protocol that's called robots exclusion
protocol that allows you to say I want
you to crawl this but I don't want you
to show any images or I want you to
crawl this but I don't want you to show
snippets oh that's too much I only want
you to show a headline so there's a
range of controls that publishers have
so you know but I'm I'm probably not the
right person to get into the legal
debate and the ins and out a fair using
other than they say that we respect
copyright law but there's doesn't even
need to be at that stage because the
publishers don't want us to index their
information and don't feel that we're
delivering value to them they're in
complete control about whether or not
they whether or not we're able to index
it there in complete control about
whether or not they want to charge that
information a charge for that
information or not